Hey guys, it's Joel with the Tapri therapy collective podcast and now we're going to do a meditation on archetypes this fits Jungian psychology if you're coming from that background, it's also applicable to something like IFS therapy Internal family systems really any kind of parts based therapy That helps you feel the tension between parts of self and recognize them as a multiplicity, yourself as a multiplicity, and follow them back into the places where they have been affected and developed over the course of the life.
大家好，我是Tapri治疗集体播客的Joel。现在我们要进行一场关于原型的冥想。如果你有荣格心理学的背景，这很适合你；它也适用于像IFS（内在家庭系统）治疗这类方法，或者任何基于“部分”的疗法。这些疗法能帮助你感受自我各部分之间的张力，认识到你自身的多重性，并追溯它们在生命历程中是如何受到影响和发展的。
And before we start I want you to find a comfortable position, seated, crouching or lying down. And allow your body to settle into a posture that feels aligned and at ease. And close your eyes and take a few deep breaths all the way in hold it and out and let go of any tension or preoccupation with each exhalation for a few minutes before we start and bring your awareness inward. I notice the sensations and rhythms of your physical being. One way to do that, to check in with your body, is to imagine a point of light forming and brightening at the tips of your toes and then running
在开始之前，请找一个舒适的姿势，坐着、蹲着或躺着都可以。让你的身体进入一种感到协调和放松的姿势。闭上眼睛，深呼吸，吸气，屏住呼吸，然后呼气。在开始前的几分钟里，随着每一次呼气，释放所有的紧张和忧虑，将你的意识转向内心。注意你身体存在的感受和节奏。检查身体的一种方法是，想象一个光点在你的脚趾尖形成并变亮，然后向上移动。
all the way up through your ankles and your knees and your thighs and your pelvis and your spine and across your heart and your arms and up your neck and through the top of your head and then just let the ball of light bounce back and forth for a minute so that you enter physical awareness or what we would call a theta wave in the QAG brain mapping lab at Taproot. And we'll begin by attuning to the warrior archetype. This is the assertive self. And it may have a different name and the type of therapy that you do, but just notice the part of you that is the part that sets boundaries and makes decisions, tries to be logical and objective a lot of the time.
穿过你的脚踝、膝盖、大腿、骨盆和脊柱，穿过你的心脏、手臂，向上经过脖子，穿过头顶。然后让那个光球来回跳动一分钟，这样你就进入了身体意识，或者我们在Taproot的QAG脑图实验室中所说的“θ波”状态。我们将从调谐“战士”原型开始。这是“主张自我的自我”。在你的治疗类型中，它可能有不同的名称，但只需注意你身上那个设定界限、做出决定、试图保持逻辑和客观的部分。
And it protects what we value, it protects our values and it represents our ability to assert our own needs, stand our ground and fight for what we believe in, to have confrontation with others. It says it's not my job to do that. When we have a healthy relationship with our inner warrior we feel confident. The warrior also holds accountability and it's capable and it's often energetic and animating, physically animating and our posture is upright and alert and our muscles are toned and responsive and our body is ready for action and our breath is deep and charging and when we're in touch with the warrior we meet challenge head-on trusting our strength and resilience to carry us through. It is deeply has a deep sense of faith in the self
它保护我们所珍视的东西，保护我们的价值观，代表了我们主张自身需求、坚持立场、为信仰而战以及与他人对抗的能力。它会说“这不是我的工作”。当我们与内在的战士有健康的关系时，我们会感到自信。战士也承担责任，它是有能力的，通常充满活力，在身体上是活跃的，我们的姿势挺拔警觉，肌肉紧致且反应灵敏，身体随时准备行动，呼吸深沉且充满力量。当我们与战士建立联系时，我们会直面挑战，相信自己的力量和韧性能够支撑我们度过难关。它对自我有着深厚的信念。
has a deep sense of faith in the self and itself as archetype does. And if our early experiences of asserting ourselves were met with opposition or criticism or outright danger, we may still have learned to fear or suppress our warrior energy and we may slouch or hide making ourselves small and invisible not wanting to be seen not wanting to stand up with broad shoulders and a straight spine and our nose pointed outward and our chin tilted up to meet someone's gaze and our muscles can become tight and immobile frozen in a state of self-protection. And our breath is shallow and hesitant and unable to fully take in life when we're out of touch with our warrior.
它对自我有着深厚的信念，作为原型本身也是如此。如果我们在早期主张自我的经历中遭遇了反对、批评或直接的危险，我们可能已经学会了恐惧或压抑我们的战士能量。我们可能会弯腰驼背或躲藏起来，让自己变得渺小且隐形，不想被看见，不想挺起肩膀、挺直脊梁，不想昂首挺胸去迎接他人的目光。我们的肌肉会变得紧绷、僵硬，处于一种自我保护的冻结状态。当我们与战士失去联系时，我们的呼吸会变得浅而迟疑，无法充分地拥抱生活。
And we may struggle with fatigue or passivity or victimhood and lack the vitality and direction of the warrior spirit. And some of us may have grown up in homes with domineering or aggressive or abusive authority figures that didn't give us room to develop our own agency. We can only have agency within system, within hierarchy, and the warrior is allowed there in sports or in business, but not other places in life where we can hold authority to
我们可能会陷入疲劳、被动或受害者心态，缺乏战士精神的活力和方向感。我们中的一些人可能在充满专横、攻击性或虐待性权威人物的家庭中长大，他们没有给我们发展自主权的空间。我们只能在系统内、在等级制度内拥有自主权，战士在体育或商业领域是被允许的，但在生活的其他地方，我们无法行使权威来……
change our mind to be different. In our attempts to stand up for ourselves, we may have been repeatedly overpowered or punished or judged, even silently leading us to feel fundamentally helpless and afraid of our own inner power. And we may continue to attract and submit to bullying personalities, never feeling safe enough to speak up and show up for what we want. And others may have witnessed and absorbed the destructive rage of a parent or caregiver and internalized the message that anger can only ever be expressed through violence and intimidation. This is an over identified warrior. We're terrified of becoming like them, like the abuser, so we push down
改变主意或变得与众不同。在我们试图坚持自我时，我们可能反复被压制、惩罚或评判，甚至是在沉默中，这导致我们感到根本性的无助，并害怕自己内在的力量。我们可能会继续吸引并屈服于霸凌型人格，从未感到足够安全去发声并争取我们想要的东西。其他人可能目睹并吸收了父母或照顾者破坏性的愤怒，内化了“愤怒只能通过暴力和恐吓来表达”的信息。这是一个过度认同的战士。我们害怕变得像他们——像施虐者一样，所以我们压抑……
our life force and we numb our passion and assertiveness in an effort to stay safe and good and we associate de-escalating to the point of enabling with being good because we don't hurt people for any reason. And sometimes your path may hurt people in a way that in the long run is best for them and best for you. The temporary honesty, the temporary conflict outweighs the good. If you're under identified with your warrior, you may not be able to make contact with that.
我们的生命力，麻痹了我们的激情和主张能力，以求保持安全和“善良”。我们将“降级到纵容的程度”与“善良”联系在一起，因为我们不想以任何理由伤害他人。有时，你的道路可能会以一种长远来看对他们和对你都最好的方式伤害他人。暂时的诚实、暂时的冲突胜过那种“好”。如果你对战士的认同不足，你可能无法接触到这一点。
You may bottle up fury and then it leaks out sideways to other parts of life through projection. Or it you explode and then feel bad and feel guilty. Or we adopt of a persona of exaggerated niceness and accommodation. If that's the case, remember Alfred Adler's admonition that it is compensation for a place where we were wounded and that even if it feels scary or like it will make you an abusive to follow your own path that's not true. Remember Albert Ellis's admonition that it is pathological to want to be liked by everybody 100% of the time sometimes the right thing to do and the good thing to do is to piss someone off and on the hand, if our youthful aggression was overindulged or even encouraged
你可能会压抑愤怒，然后它通过投射泄露到生活的其他部分。或者你爆发了，然后感到糟糕和内疚。或者我们采取了一种夸张的友善和迁就的人格面具。如果是这样，请记住阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒的告诫：这是对我们受伤之处的补偿。即使追随自己的道路让你感到害怕，或者让你觉得会变得像个施虐者，那也不是真的。记住阿尔伯特·埃利斯的告诫：想要100%的时间都被所有人喜欢是病态的。有时，正确且善良的做法就是去惹恼某人。另一方面，如果我们在年轻时的攻击性被过度放纵甚至鼓励……
without limits and without guidance, we may compensate by becoming rigidly armored and domineering and our posture can become puffed up and imposing and our muscles tense and bulging and everything becomes a contest. We don't understand life without a fight. We don't understand life without dominance. Life without games. Things that strip life of its color. We're always trying to understand the game we're playing and to win.
且没有限制和引导，我们可能会通过变得僵化、武装和专横来补偿。我们的姿势会变得膨胀且咄咄逼人，肌肉紧张隆起，一切都变成了竞争。我们无法理解没有战斗的生活。我们无法理解没有支配的生活。没有游戏的生活。那些剥夺了生活色彩的东西。我们总是试图理解我们正在玩的游戏并试图获胜。
If we're over identified with the warrior and our breath is forceful and erratic and it's always ready to explode into action and we may intimidate and control others and endlessly be defensive or hostile leaving a trail of damage in our wake because when life is a game we become perfectionists. Some of us may have been given the message that we had to be tough and invulnerable to survive and that any sign of softness or sensitivity was an unforgivable weakness. And driven by a desperate need to prove ourselves, we relentlessly pushed past our limits, ignoring signals of pain and exhaustion.
如果我们过度认同战士，我们的呼吸会变得剧烈且不稳定，随时准备爆发行动。我们可能会恐吓和控制他人，不断地防御或敌对，在我们身后留下一片破坏的痕迹。因为当生活是一场游戏时，我们就会变成完美主义者。我们中的一些人可能被灌输了“必须强硬且刀枪不入才能生存，任何软弱或敏感的迹象都是不可原谅的弱点”的信息。在证明自己的迫切需求驱动下，我们无情地超越极限，忽视了疼痛和疲惫的信号。
And we become fixated on conquest and domination in all arenas, from the boardroom to the bedroom, terrified of ever letting down our guard. And others may have grown up in a chaotic or dangerous environment plagued by the threat of violation or abandonment and without any sense of safety or stability we armor ourselves in layers of aggression and defiance, always pretending to fight or to flee and we remain perpetually on edge. And unable to trust or truly connect, we act out cycles of explosive rage and then crushing shame. So take a few moments to reflect on your relationship with your warrior. What messages did you absorb about anger, assertiveness, and power in your early life?
我们变得执着于在所有领域进行征服和统治，从董事会到卧室，害怕放下防备。其他人可能在混乱或危险的环境中长大，饱受侵犯或遗弃的威胁，在没有任何安全感或稳定感的情况下，我们用层层攻击和反抗武装自己，总是假装战斗或逃跑，我们始终处于边缘状态。由于无法信任或真正建立联系，我们陷入了爆发性愤怒和毁灭性羞耻的循环。所以，花点时间反思一下你与战士的关系。你在早年生活中吸收了关于愤怒、主张和权力的什么信息？
All of these archetypes can show up one way at church, one way at home, one way with children, one way with women, one way with girls, one way with boys, one way with men, one way in groups. They're all places where we have different relationships to these things. They're not gods, they're parts of our psychology. They're networks of brain chemistry, different parts of the brain, all different assumptions and associations.
所有这些原型都可能以某种方式出现在教堂、家里、与孩子相处时、与女性相处时、与女孩相处时、与男孩相处时、与男人相处时、在群体中。这些都是我们与这些事物有不同关系的地方。它们不是神，它们是我们心理的一部分。它们是脑化学网络，是大脑的不同部分，有着各种不同的假设和联想。
different parts of the brain that hold different assumptions and associations. So how does your body hold the imprints of those experiences? Without judgment, simply notice what rises up and breathe into those places with care. You may want to invite your warrior energy to express itself in a healthy way, perhaps by standing up tall and strong, straightening the spine and lifting the chin and broadening the shoulders, not clenching the fingers but holding them loose or in a slightly loose fist. And you'll feel this fire igniting from your solar plexus and infusing you with this whole being
大脑的不同部分持有不同的假设和联想。那么你的身体是如何承载这些经历的印记的呢？不要评判，只需注意升起的东西，并带着关怀向这些地方呼吸。你可能想邀请你的战士能量以健康的方式表达出来，也许是通过站得高大强壮，挺直脊柱，抬起下巴，舒展肩膀，不要紧握手指，而是让它们放松，或者握成一个稍微松散的拳头。你会感觉到这股火从你的太阳神经丛点燃，并注入你的整个存在。
With courage and determination and this is something that you do deserve Now we're gonna shift to the magician archetype and the magician is the part of us That perceives the hidden dynamics at play in all parts of life, politics, religion, advertising, office politics, family structure, society, and it transforms reality, the magician does, through our own intention and skill, and it lets us activate powerful intuitions. But if we're not careful, we may not be able to tell those intuitions from traumas. And find clever solutions to tricky problems. That's
带着勇气和决心，这是你应得的。现在我们要转向“魔术师”原型。魔术师是我们身上感知生活各方面隐藏动态的部分——政治、宗教、广告、办公室政治、家庭结构、社会。它通过我们自己的意图和技能转化现实，魔术师让我们激活强大的直觉。但如果我们不小心，我们可能无法将这些直觉与创伤区分开来。并为棘手的问题找到巧妙的解决方案。这就是……
what the magician does. Problems other people can't solve or don't even see. And it represents our access to knowledge and ingenuity and creative power. And when we're in touch with our inner magician we feel imaginative and intuitive and fluid and our senses are heightened and receptive picking up subtle cues and energies and our hands are dexterous and expressive weaving meaning through word and gesture and our posture is loose like a kung-fu fighter, ready to entertain and to reach forward to people or reach out to a new experience, and our minds are quick and flexible and able to shape-shift between multiple perspectives.
魔术师所做的。别人无法解决甚至看不到的问题。它代表了我们获取知识、独创性和创造力的途径。当我们与内在的魔术师建立联系时，我们会感到富有想象力、直觉敏锐且灵活。我们的感官变得敏锐且具有接受力，能捕捉到细微的线索和能量。我们的双手灵巧且富有表现力，通过言语和手势编织意义。我们的姿势像功夫高手一样放松，准备好娱乐他人，向人们伸出援手或接触新的体验。我们的思维敏捷灵活，能够在多种视角之间切换。
However, if our innate sensitivity and curiosity were chronically dismissed, ignored, or even punished, in childhood we may become disconnected from our magical capacities and our bodies feel wooden and numb and they move mechanically without inspiration or joy. And our faces fall into a blank mask, hiding our true thoughts and feelings. And our minds are dull and they're literalistic, and they're unable to read between the lines or envision new possibilities. And we may plod through life in a state of boredom and cynicism and cut off from the wonder
然而，如果我们的天生敏感和好奇心在童年时期被长期忽视、无视甚至惩罚，我们可能会与我们的魔法能力断开连接。我们的身体感觉木讷麻木，机械地移动，没有灵感或快乐。我们的脸陷入空白的面具，隐藏了我们真实的想法和感受。我们的思维迟钝且字面化，无法读懂言外之意或设想新的可能性。我们可能会在无聊和愤世嫉俗的状态下度过一生，与奇迹隔绝……
and mystery of existence. And some of us have been told that our questions and ideas were silly, were not realistic, they're strange, or they're disruptive, and that they would want us to stick to practical matters and leave the fanciful dreaming to someone else, or to tradition, or to hierarchies. And if you are shamed for gifts of observation and imagination, then we detach from them retreating into the gray fog of convention. And we may discount our intuition and we may second-guess our innovative solutions or we may fail to speak up when
和存在的奥秘。我们中的一些人被告知我们的问题和想法很愚蠢、不现实、奇怪或具有破坏性，他们希望我们坚持实际问题，把异想天开留给别人、传统或等级制度。如果你因为观察和想象的天赋而感到羞耻，那么我们就会脱离它们，退回到传统的灰色迷雾中。我们可能会否定自己的直觉，可能会对自己的创新解决方案产生怀疑，或者当我们……
we don't see, when we see what others don't see. And others may have pigeonholed us as the smart one in the family or pressured us to perform academically while our other needs went unmet. Because if you're over identified with the warrior, you're going to have a lot of other people's projection on you. People who mistake you for their own self-image and over-identify with you and then attack you and radically under-identify with you because you're reminding them of a capacity they were cut off from. And that can happen with any archetype, but with a magician especially. People are attracted to you and then they expect you to be something you may not want to be and these early childhood patterns are reinforced. And if we were praised maybe for intellectual prowess or wit,
看不到时，或者当我们看到别人看不到的东西时，我们可能无法发声。其他人可能把我们归类为家里“聪明的那一个”，或者在我们的其他需求未得到满足时强迫我们取得学术成就。因为如果你过度认同战士，你就会承受很多别人的投射。那些把你误认为他们自己形象的人，过度认同你，然后攻击你，或者因为你提醒了他们被切断的能力而极度不认同你。这在任何原型中都可能发生，但对魔术师来说尤其如此。人们被你吸引，然后期望你成为你可能不想成为的样子，这些童年早期的模式被强化了。如果我们因为智力或机智而受到赞扬，
we become over identified with our mental capacities and we neglect the intelligence of our bodies and our hearts and we're driven by a compulsive need to figure everything out, to understand every facet, every root, every current of life all the time. And we overthink ourselves into paralysis and disconnect from our instinctual wisdom because our curiosity has become co-opted by trauma. And we're really trying to learn not to experience the beauty of life, but to keep ourselves safe by not acknowledging some childhood wound. And on the other hand, some of us relied on our cleverness and our charm to navigate frightening or chaotic early environments. And without a foundation of safety and security, we survived by staying one step ahead and reading the room and giving
我们就会过度认同我们的心理能力，而忽视了身体和心灵的智慧。我们被一种强迫性的需求所驱动，想要弄清楚一切，理解生活的每一个侧面、每一个根源、每一股潮流。我们过度思考以至于瘫痪，并与本能的智慧断开连接，因为我们的好奇心已经被创伤所利用。我们实际上是在试图学习如何不去体验生活的美好，而是通过不承认某种童年创伤来保护自己。另一方面，我们中的一些人依靠聪明才智和魅力来应对令人恐惧或混乱的早期环境。在没有安全感和保障的基础上，我们通过保持领先一步、观察环境并给予……
others what they wanted from us. Highly attuned to what was hidden under the surface we anticipated so that we could avoid danger, so that we could figure out a way to get around the problem to not be hurt again. And if you took advantage of these opportunities, you know, you learn to hide hurt parts of yourself. And others may have dealt with situations that felt out of control by retreating into fantasy and magical thinking. And unable to influence our external circumstances, we escaped into the limitless playgrounds of imagination. And while this served an important function at the time, we may have become stuck in the patterns of wishful thinking, an avoidance passively waiting to be rescued instead of proactively shaping life.
别人想要的东西来生存。高度调谐于表面之下隐藏的东西，我们进行预判，以便避开危险，以便找到解决问题的方法，不再受到伤害。如果你利用了这些机会，你知道，你学会了隐藏自己受伤的部分。其他人可能通过退缩到幻想和魔法思维中来处理感觉失控的情况。由于无法影响外部环境，我们逃进了想象力的无限游乐场。虽然这在当时发挥了重要作用，但我们可能陷入了“一厢情愿”和“回避”的模式，被动地等待被拯救，而不是主动地塑造生活。
And alternatively if our early curiosity and exploration were met with consistent encouragement and guidance then we may have become overly enchanted by esoteric things and exceptionalism and we become addicted to complexity and specialness. We get lost in arcane theories and niche interests and we neglect the practical foundations of existence and life like routine, like bodies, like time, like money, like diet, like substance use because for an intuitive feeler, for someone who the magician comes naturally to, limitations are the shadow that not everyone accesses and realizes their potential. We get lost in visions of what the future could be, and sometimes we forget what it can't be because of other people's
或者，如果我们的早期好奇心和探索得到了持续的鼓励和引导，那么我们可能会过度沉迷于深奥的事物和特殊性，我们变得沉迷于复杂性和特殊感。我们迷失在晦涩的理论和利基兴趣中，忽视了存在的实际基础，比如常规、身体、时间、金钱、饮食、物质使用。因为对于一个直觉型的人，对于一个魔术师特质自然流露的人来说，局限性是阴影，并不是每个人都能接触到并意识到他们的潜力。我们迷失在对未来的愿景中，有时我们忘记了因为别人的……
choices. We see what we want to see and like the sorcerer's apprentice we play with forces we don't fully understand and we fail to ground our knowledge and embodied experience or in logic or in physical embodiment. And take a moment to sense into your own relationship with the magician archetype. When did you first feel the most imaginative? When did you perceive perception? When did you become
选择，有些事情是无法实现的。我们看到我们想看到的东西，就像《魔法师的学徒》一样，我们玩弄着我们并不完全理解的力量，我们未能将我们的知识建立在具体的体验、逻辑或身体体现上。花点时间感受一下你与魔术师原型的关系。你什么时候感到最有想象力？你什么时候感知到了感知？你什么时候变得……
intellectually agile? Either introvertedly in a book, picking apart films and stories, or extrovertly by figuring out what people really were saying, what they really wanted. The secret games of communication that were going on. When did those qualities feel blocked, denied, or distorted,
智力敏捷吗？要么是内向地沉浸在书中，剖析电影和故事；要么是外向地去弄清楚人们到底在说什么，他们真正想要的是什么。那些正在进行的秘密沟通游戏。这些品质在什么时候感到被阻碍、被否定或被扭曲了，
and how do you hold these patterns in your physical and mental habits today? You might experiment with awakening your magician energy in a generative way, letting your senses attune to the nuances and the shades of your environment, moving your hands to craft meaning and beauty, or allowing your mind to dream up whimsical new ideas. Feel your third eye chakra as the Hindus and some of the Eastern Medicine practitioners would say, open and illuminate and bring clarity and possibility to your inner and outer worlds. Now we'll invoke the Queen Archetype, the part of us that nurtures and empowers and influences others through our receptive
以及你今天如何在你的身体和心理习惯中保持这些模式？你可以尝试以一种创造性的方式唤醒你的魔术师能量，让你的感官去适应环境的细微差别和色调，移动你的双手去创造意义和美，或者让你的思想构思出异想天开的新点子。感受你的第三眼脉轮，正如印度教徒和一些东方医学从业者所说的那样，打开并照亮，为你的内在和外在世界带来清晰和可能性。现在我们将召唤女王原型，这是我们通过接受性的
presence and emotional attunement. And the Queen represents our capacity to be with the full spectrum of human experience, pleasure and pain, light and shadow, yours and mine. When we are anchored in our Queen energy we feel compassionate and generous and at ease in our own skin It's a maternal force that is nurturing and creative but creative on others behalf And our posture is relaxed and open and our shoulders down Our belly is soft and our arms are ready to reach out and wrap around
存在和情感调谐来滋养、赋能和影响他人的那部分。女王代表了我们与人类体验的全谱共处的能力，无论是快乐还是痛苦，光明还是阴影，你的还是我的。当我们锚定在女王能量中时，我们感到富有同情心、慷慨大方，并且在自己的皮肤里感到自在。这是一种母性的力量，它是滋养和创造性的，但这种创造是为了他人的利益。我们的姿势放松而开放，肩膀下垂，腹部柔软，双臂准备好伸出并环绕
and embrace and we listen are ready to reach out and wrap around and embrace and we listen deeply and reflect humbly and respond with care and wisdom. Others are naturally drawn to us finding our company a sense of being soothed and uplifted and inspired. However, if your feelings and needs went chronically unmet in childhood, we may struggle to embody the Queen's loving confidence. If our attempts to share our inner world were rejected, ignored, or misunderstood, we may have withdrawn into a state of silent suffering and if we were punished or shamed for having big emotions, for reacting with too much empathy, too much becoming sad when we saw somebody on the street or somebody getting hurt on TV, we may try and control and compartmentalize or cut off our feeling nature.
并拥抱，我们倾听，准备好伸出双臂去环绕和拥抱，我们深刻地倾听，谦卑地反思，并以关怀和智慧回应。他人自然会被我们吸引，在我们的陪伴中感到一种被抚慰、被提升和被激励的感觉。然而，如果你的感受和需求在童年时期长期得不到满足，我们可能难以体现女王那种充满爱的自信。如果我们分享内心世界的尝试被拒绝、忽视或误解，我们可能已经退缩到一种沉默的痛苦状态；如果我们因为拥有强烈的情感、因为反应出太多的同情心——比如在街上看到某人或在电视上看到某人受伤时变得太难过——而受到惩罚或羞辱，我们可能会试图控制、划分或切断我们的情感本性。
If we experience suffocating enmeshment or role reversal or parentificate we were parentified as a child by lack of ability or neglect on behalf of the parent and we had to become the parent too soon, we may compulsively focus on others to the point of losing ourselves. We may become locked into a false dichotomy where having needs makes us needy and putting ourselves last makes us good. And especially women socialized to be self-sacrificing, may be over-identified with this.
如果我们经历了令人窒息的纠缠、角色反转，或者在童年时期因为父母的能力不足或忽视而被“父母化”，我们不得不过早地成为父母，我们可能会强迫性地关注他人，以至于迷失了自我。我们可能会陷入一种错误的二分法，即有需求就意味着“需要帮助”，而把别人放在第一位才意味着我们是“好人”。特别是那些被社会化为自我牺牲的女性，可能对此过度认同。
Men may have a martyr complex and feel like they have to die or kill part of themselves in order for other people to be happy. And they may provide things that are not even needed. And deeply afraid of disappointment and abandonment, we may extend ourselves way beyond our capacity only to end up feeling depleted and resentful. Or we may go to the other extreme of refusing all
男性可能会有殉道者情结，觉得为了让别人快乐，他们必须牺牲或扼杀自己的一部分。他们可能会提供一些甚至并不需要的东西。由于对失望和被抛弃的深深恐惧，我们可能会过度付出，超出了我们的能力范围，最终感到精疲力竭和怨恨。或者我们可能会走向另一个极端，拒绝一切
help and support as a way to stay strong and autonomous. We often privatize and minimize pain. We've been taught it's too much for others to see. It'll hurt them. And that privatized pain makes us unconscious of our own experience of suffering and so we become hypersensitive or oversensitive at strange times. And we may struggle to set boundaries or say no. We may overly fear loss of connection and approval when there's little to no risk of that. And we may overcompensate by micromanaging or controlling or having an artificial affirmation or an artificial positivity that
帮助和支持，以此作为保持强大和自主的一种方式。我们经常将痛苦私有化和最小化。我们被教导说，让别人看到这些太沉重了，会伤害到他们。这种私有化的痛苦使我们对自己的痛苦体验失去知觉，因此我们在奇怪的时候变得过度敏感或神经过敏。我们可能难以设定界限或说“不”。我们可能过度担心失去联系和认可，即使这种风险微乎其微。我们可能会通过微观管理、控制或拥有某种人为的肯定或人为的积极性来过度补偿，而这种积极性
is avoidant. We may contort ourselves to try and fill in the gaps and smooth over the edges in our relationships and we may martyr ourselves and call it love. And when we're disconnected from our authentic queen, we often feel consumed by everyone else's feelings and everyone else's problems but numb and inarticulate or fuzzy about our own. And we may become paralyzed by indecision, unable to get in touch with our deeper values and desires. And we may look to gurus and experts to tell us who we are and how to live. And alienated from our intuition, we feel for situations.
是回避性的。我们可能会扭曲自己，试图填补空白并抚平人际关系中的棱角，我们可能会自我牺牲并称之为爱。当我们与真实的“女王”断开连接时，我们经常感到被他人的感受和问题所吞噬，但对自己却感到麻木、表达不清或模糊。我们可能会因优柔寡断而瘫痪，无法触及我们更深层的价值观和欲望。我们可能会寻找大师和专家来告诉我们是谁以及如何生活。由于与直觉疏远，我们对局势感到迷茫。
We overthink and second-guess ourselves. And we may attempt to heal and transform others without their consent, trying to give them the help that we need. And remember if you're under-identified with a queen and you're projecting onto gurus and prophets and spiritual advisors and bosses and co-workers or people you see and speak with that don't deserve the projection. Remember that they're only reminding you of that spark of yourself out here that you're cut off from. And once you manifest it and reconnect with that energy, you won't feel that way anymore. On the other extreme, when we're over identified with the shadowy queen we become dramatically attached to our moods and our miseries like a black hole
我们过度思考并怀疑自己。我们可能会试图在未经他人同意的情况下治愈和改变他人，试图给予他们我们自己所需要的帮助。记住，如果你与女王原型认同不足，并且你正在将这种能量投射到那些不值得投射的大师、先知、精神导师、老板、同事或你见到并交谈的人身上。记住，他们只是在提醒你，你身上那部分被切断的火花。一旦你显化并重新连接上那种能量，你就不会再有那种感觉了。在另一个极端，当我们过度认同阴影女王时，我们会变得戏剧性地依附于我们的情绪和苦难，就像一个黑洞
of need we pull on others to fill an inner void. And we may confuse intensity with intimacy and attempt to rush into merging and we may perceive problems everywhere and appoint ourselves as the one to solve all of them and hooked on the validation that comes from helping we don't allow others the dignity of their own journey. We can't let go the maternal hug, the maternal embrace, we can't open our arms and let our children grow up and And we may start to see our worth as dependent on how much we've sacrificed. And take a few moments to attune to your inner queen if any of this resonated with you. Where in your body do you notice the presence or the
一样，我们拉扯他人来填补内心的空虚。我们可能会混淆强度与亲密感，并试图匆忙地融合；我们可能会到处看到问题，并任命自己为解决所有问题的人；沉迷于帮助他人带来的认可感，我们没有给予他人走自己旅程的尊严。我们无法放开母性的拥抱，我们无法张开双臂让我们的孩子长大。我们可能会开始认为我们的价值取决于我们牺牲了多少。如果这些内容引起了你的共鸣，请花点时间调整你的内在女王。你在身体的哪个部位注意到了这种
absence of the Queen's empowered compassion? What happens in your nervous system and energy field when you contemplate opening to witness the truth of your feelings and those of others. What traumas and internalized beliefs block your access to the wise and the warm boundary love that is your essence. What shifts as you practice embodying unconditional acceptance and holding space for yourself and for the world. And feel down into your gut and affirm your right to take up space and to tend to your own needs and your own hurts, to mother yourself with exquisite attunement and from this place of inner communion feel the spaciousness
女王赋能的同情心的存在或缺失？当你考虑敞开心扉去见证你自己的感受以及他人的感受时，你的神经系统和能量场会发生什么？什么样的创伤和内在化的信念阻碍了你获得那种作为你本质的智慧和温暖的界限之爱？当你练习体现无条件的接纳并为自己和世界留出空间时，会有什么转变？深入你的腹部，确认你有权占据空间，有权照顾自己的需求和伤痛，以精致的调谐来母育你自己。从这个内在交流的地方，感受那种
that arises in your heart, your capacity to unfold all beings and all experiences into your vast embrace and warmly accept them but not hold on too tight and not abandoning yourself and not abandoning others, trusting the intelligent unfolding of each soul's sovereign path, and resting in the knowing that all is welcome and all is workable and all is well. And now I want you to settle into the King archetype. And the King is the part of us that sits in the center, the still point from which we orient our path of purpose. It is our capacity to see the big picture, to lead from a place of integrity and inspiration. But it's a
在你心中升起的广阔感，你将所有众生和所有经历纳入你广阔怀抱的能力，温暖地接纳它们，但不要抓得太紧，不要抛弃自己，也不要抛弃他人，信任每个灵魂主权道路的智慧展开，并安住在“一切都受欢迎，一切皆可处理，一切都很好”的认知中。现在，我想让你沉淀到国王原型中。国王是我们内在坐在中心的部分，是我们确定目标路径的静止点。它是我们从正直和灵感出发去领导的能力。但这是一个
goal-focused big picture. It's not the deep esoteria and complex systems of the magician. It is a purpose and effective orientation. And when we are rooted in the king we feel clear and confident and in flow with a larger order and our posture is upright without being rigid and stable and poised like a mountain and our breath is slow and deep and anchoring and our presence is reassuring to those around us and our voice resonates with a quiet power and a profound simplicity of speech not the flowery ornamentation or the deflection or the misdirection of the magician. And we're able to hold all the ideas of many and chart a course that blends the interests of one into
以目标为导向的大局观。它不是魔术师那种深奥的玄学和复杂的系统。它是一种目标和有效的导向。当我们扎根于国王能量时，我们感到清晰、自信，并与更大的秩序保持一致；我们的姿势挺拔而不僵硬，像山一样稳定而从容；我们的呼吸缓慢、深沉且具有锚定作用；我们的存在让周围的人感到安心；我们的声音带着一种安静的力量和深刻的言语简洁性，而不是魔术师那种华丽的修辞、转移或误导。我们能够容纳许多人的所有想法，并规划出一条将个人利益与
the needs of all. But for many of us this kind of centered integrative leadership is a distant dream and buffeted by the winds of our traumatic histories and unconscious patterns we often feel like lost children, more so than sovereign rulers of our own realms that are in chaos. And if we grew up in chaotic, neglectful, or abusive homes, we may struggle to develop a coherent sense of self around which to order our inner and outer world. And overwhelmed by a constant sense of crisis, we careen from one fire to the next, rarely feeling on top of things. And without a foundation of safety and stability, it can be hard to relax into our executive functioning, our ability to plan and prioritize and organize and follow through to the end.
所有人的需求融合在一起的道路。但对于我们许多人来说，这种以中心为导向的整合式领导力是一个遥远的梦想。在创伤历史和无意识模式的风暴中，我们常常感觉自己像迷路的孩子，而不是自己混乱领域的主权统治者。如果我们成长在混乱、忽视或虐待的家庭中，我们可能难以围绕一个连贯的自我感来整理我们的内在和外在世界。被持续的危机感所淹没，我们从一个火坑冲向另一个火坑，很少感到掌控一切。如果没有安全和稳定的基础，就很难放松进入我们的执行功能，即规划、优先排序、组织并坚持到底的能力。
Not to start a million things with the energy of the warrior, but to bring all things to a conclusion. And instead we procrastinate and avoid and escape into addiction and distraction and become scattered and forgetful, and we may chronically underestimate the time and energy required to meet our goals or set our sights so low that we never actualize our potential. And crushed by the weight of a backlog of unmet needs and unresolved issues, we may despair of ever getting on top of it all. And having never gotten the proper mirroring,
不是用战士的能量开始一百万件事，而是将所有事情带向结论。相反，我们拖延、回避，逃避到成瘾和分心中，变得分散和健忘；我们可能会长期低估实现目标所需的时间和精力，或者将目标定得太低，以至于永远无法实现我们的潜力。被积压的未满足需求和未解决问题的重压所压垮，我们可能会对掌控一切感到绝望。由于从未得到适当的镜像、
modeling, and mentoring, we may have a hard time envisioning a life of meaningful contribution and self-actualization. We may develop doubt. We may have a lack of faith in our ability to make good decisions, to pass judgments, to hold authority in roles that others nominate us for. We're always looking to others to make up our minds for us and we may shrink from positions of responsibility, isolate into a small and unthreatening existence, or wrestle, you know, job hop, search for some elusive sense of fit that will tell us what we are. Never feeling quite ready or adequate, we hesitate to stand tall and take a definitive
建模和指导，我们可能很难设想一种有意义的贡献和自我实现的生活。我们可能会产生怀疑。我们可能对自己做出正确决定、做出判断、在他人提名的角色中保持权威的能力缺乏信心。我们总是指望别人来为我们做决定，我们可能会在责任面前退缩，孤立地生活在一个狭小且无威胁的存在中，或者挣扎，你知道，频繁跳槽，寻找某种难以捉摸的契合感来告诉我们自己是什么。因为从未感到准备好或足够好，我们犹豫着不敢挺身而出，做出决定性的
stand. But on the other hand, if we were prematurely elevated into adult roles, if we were parentified as children or forced into rigid molds of perfection, we may compensate with a tyrannical approach to life and work. We may be alienated from our authentic desires and rhythms. We drive ourselves relentlessly in service of external standards. We may become a workaholic, an uncompromising idealist, or a micromanaging control freak. More invested in appearances of competence than actual lived experience of creative effectiveness.
立场。但另一方面，如果我们过早地被提升到成人的角色，如果我们作为孩子被“父母化”或被迫进入僵化的完美模具中，我们可能会以一种暴虐的方式来对待生活和工作。我们可能与真实的欲望和节奏疏远了。我们为了外部标准而无情地驱使自己。我们可能成为工作狂、不妥协的理想主义者或微观管理的控制狂。比起创造性效能的实际生活体验，我们更看重能力的表象。
And terrified of the shame of criticism or failure, we become our own worst task masters, holding ourselves and others to impossibly high standards. We may deny our basic needs to rest, play, connect, and try to go it alone while in our inner state is steadily crumbling. and we may outwardly be successful in conventional terms while feeling inwardly empty and hypocritical, addicted to the validation that comes through visible achievement, objective measures, not the inner world of subjectivity or the imagined. subjectivity or the imagined. Now pause here and notice where these king themes come out in your life if you identify with any of the things that I said. How do you experience your own capacity for inspired and effective leadership, both
由于害怕批评或失败带来的羞耻感，我们成为了自己最糟糕的监工，对自己和他人设定了高不可攀的标准。我们可能会否认自己休息、玩耍、联系的基本需求，并试图独自承担，而我们的内在状态却在稳步崩溃。我们在传统意义上可能在外表上是成功的，但在内心却感到空虚和虚伪，沉迷于通过可见的成就和客观衡量标准获得的认可，而不是主观的内心世界或想象的世界。现在在这里暂停一下，如果你认同我所说的任何事情，请注意这些国王主题是如何在你的生活中体现出来的。你如何体验自己那种充满灵感和有效的领导能力，无论是
personally and professionally? Where are you owning your expertise? Where are you being accountable when you fail? Where are you stepping into your authority? Staying the course with your deepest values and what parts of life and what modes of thought? And where are you abdicating your power, suppressing your truth, running around in circles? What parts of you still need to be integrated to have a seat at the table inside you. Now feel your feet on the ground and the crown on your head and open up to heaven's will and breathe into your belly and your chest and allow your spine to gently lengthen up and sense the solid nature
个人还是职业方面？你在哪里拥有你的专业知识？当失败时，你在哪里承担责任？你在哪里步入你的权威？坚持你最深层的价值观，在生活的哪些部分和哪些思维模式中？你在哪里放弃了你的权力，压制了你的真相，在原地打转？你身上还有哪些部分需要整合，才能在你内心拥有一席之地。现在感受你的双脚着地，头顶皇冠，向天意敞开，呼吸进入你的腹部和胸部，让你的脊椎轻轻向上延伸，感受你背部的坚实本质，
of your back that supports you in opening your heart and walking and talking from your chest and listen for whispers of your soul that want to talk to you in these parts of the body. What would it be like to bring just a little bit of this energy into the areas of your life that you find that you shrink and that you hide behind other people. Imagine yourself wearing a crown and feel the heft of your integrity. Now we're going to move to the lover archetype. The lover is the part of self that allows us to dissolve our individuality and to be
它支持你敞开心扉，从胸中行走和交谈，倾听你灵魂的低语，它们想在身体的这些部位与你交谈。如果能将这种能量的一点点带入你发现自己退缩、躲在别人身后的生活领域，那会是什么样子？想象自己戴着皇冠，感受你正直的重量。现在我们要转向情人原型。情人是自我的一部分，它允许我们消解我们的个体性，并成为
part of a greater whole. It allows us to be a part of the unitive experiences of life that require letting go of our individuality and our defenses to be part of a greater whole. Not only within human relationships but a experience of spirituality, an experience of community, or a relationship or commitment to a greater ideological structure. The lover is our capacity intimacy and communion and total devotion to another thing, another idea, another experience, another person, another community. And when we're flowing with the love or energy we feel porous, passionate and drenched in delight or animated with ecstatic communion. Our skin tingles with sensitivity or our heartbeat might quicken with anticipation. Our breath might deepen into rapture and all of our senses become doorways to enchantment and everything becomes an invitation
一个更大整体的一部分。它允许我们成为生活统一体验的一部分，这需要放下我们的个体性和防御，成为一个更大整体的一部分。不仅是在人际关系中，而且是一种灵性的体验、社区的体验，或者对某种更大的意识形态结构的承诺。情人是我们对亲密、共融以及对另一件事、另一个想法、另一种体验、另一个人、另一个社区的完全奉献的能力。当我们与情人能量流动时，我们感到多孔、充满激情、沉浸在喜悦中，或者被狂喜的共融所激活。我们的皮肤因敏感而刺痛，或者我们的心跳可能会因期待而加快。我们的呼吸可能会加深进入狂喜，我们所有的感官都成为通往魅力的门户，一切都成为一种邀请
to merge and dissolve the illusion of the separate self. But as we already know most of us did not get the blessing to develop these potentials in a safe and nourishing container as that is so rare and many of us receive a barrage of contradictory messages about love or sexuality or religion or community or ideological structure and we don't develop an intimate bonding that created deep conflicts in our psyches and our emotional systems. And if our basic need for a warm, responsive touch went unmet, we may have ended up starved for touch,
去融合并消解独立自我的幻觉。但正如我们已经知道的那样，我们大多数人并没有得到在安全和滋养的容器中发展这些潜力的祝福，因为这太罕见了。我们许多人收到了关于爱、性、宗教、社区或意识形态结构的相互矛盾的信息，我们没有发展出亲密的联结，这在我们的心理和情感系统中造成了深刻的冲突。如果我们对温暖、回应性触摸的基本需求没有得到满足，我们可能最终会渴望触摸，
and desperately grasping at any crumbs of connection. Or we may have shut down our need for physical affection altogether to convince ourselves that we don't want it, or that it's weak, or that any attempt to get it from us is some kind of violation of our boundaries or disrespectful. And if we experienced inappropriate sexual grooming or overstimulation or violation. We may swing wildly between intense erotic charge and then intense sexual aversion, seemingly for no reason. There's an ambivalence and we may not know how to regulate our nervous system's response. And we may act out compulsively, mistaking intensity for intimacy and end up repeatedly
并绝望地抓住任何一点联系的碎片。或者我们可能完全关闭了对身体亲昵的需求，以说服自己我们不需要它，或者认为它是软弱的，或者认为任何试图从我们这里得到它的尝试都是对我们界限的某种侵犯或不尊重。如果我们经历了不适当的性诱导、过度刺激或侵犯，我们可能会在强烈的色情冲动和强烈的性厌恶之间剧烈摇摆，似乎没有任何理由。这是一种矛盾心理，我们可能不知道如何调节我们神经系统的反应。我们可能会强迫性地行事，将强度误认为是亲密感，并最终反复
traumatized. Or we may go to the other extreme of repressing our sensuality and vulnerability, living in a state disconnected from our body and from our desires and longings to be part of a bigger whole or to let our defenses down and feel trust and protection. And if we were shamed, punished, or humiliated for our natural sexual curiosity, self-exploration, or simply our desire to dissolve our identity and participate in anything, if that was judged, we may continue to carry a deep sense of unworthiness, a feeling of being dirty or broken or unwanted, or an inability to trust and feel safe. And this can show up as an inhibited, constricted relationship
受到创伤。或者我们可能会走向另一个极端，压抑我们的感官和脆弱性，生活在一种与身体断开连接的状态中，与我们想要成为更大整体一部分的欲望和渴望断开连接，或者无法放下防御去感受信任和保护。如果我们因为自然的性好奇心、自我探索，或者仅仅因为我们想要消解身份并参与任何事物的欲望而受到羞辱、惩罚或贬低，如果这些被评判，我们可能会继续背负一种深深的无价值感，一种感到肮脏、破碎或不被需要的感觉，或者一种无法信任和感到安全的能力。这可能表现为一种受抑制、紧缩的关系。
with our own erotic nature or our own sense of boundaries and community and where we go through all of the motions of intimacy without really letting ourselves feel and it can also manifest as a pattern of pursuing sexuality in a degrading or dangerous context as a way to confirm our worst fears or confront our worst fears. And either way we are riddled with anxiety and self-loathing. And if we grew up surrounded by repressive, traditional, hierarchical, or sexually negative attitudes, where the body and its desires and needs were seen as sinful or animalistic or immature, we may struggle
或是我们自身的色欲本质，又或是我们对界限和社区的感知。我们走过亲密关系的所有流程，却并未真正让自己去感受。这也可能表现为一种在贬低或危险的环境中追求性行为的模式，以此来确认或面对我们内心最深的恐惧。无论哪种方式，我们都饱受焦虑和自我厌恶的折磨。如果我们成长在充满压抑、传统、等级森严或性负面态度的环境中，身体及其欲望和需求被视为罪恶、兽性或不成熟，我们可能会挣扎
to embrace our love or nature at all. And when we are alienated from these things, we live mostly in our heads because our hearts are armored and our body can feel numb. And we may pride ourselves on being above baser instincts while our unlived life festers in the basement of our mind and our body. And this can breed a susceptibility to sudden lapses into destructive excesses, followed by renewed vows and purity and self-control. And this is incredibly important when we are exploring our relationships to substance use,
于拥抱我们的爱或本性。当我们与这些事物疏离时，我们大多活在头脑中，因为我们的心被武装起来，身体感到麻木。我们可能以超越低级本能而自豪，而我们未曾活出的生命却在心智和身体的地下室里腐烂。这可能滋生出一种突然陷入破坏性放纵的易感性，随后又重新发誓保持纯洁和自控。当我们探索与物质使用、
obsession or addiction, because the lover when it is unconscious can manifest as a desire to be completely dissolved, for the mind to be completely turned off by a substance or a person or an experience and then a rigid judgment of that and clinging to a white-knuckling of control and then a relapse or a re-experiencing of that pattern over and over. And then on the other side if we were exposed to an onslaught of hyper-sexualized media and messaging about conforming identities and mandatory participation in a interpersonal or community experience.
强迫症或成瘾的关系时，这一点极其重要。因为当“爱人”原型处于无意识状态时，它可能表现为一种完全消融的渴望，希望通过某种物质、某个人或某种体验让大脑彻底关机，随后是对这种行为的僵化评判，紧接着是死死抓住控制权，然后是复发，或者一遍又一遍地重演这种模式。另一方面，如果我们暴露在大量过度性化的媒体和关于从众身份、强制参与人际或社区体验的信息轰炸中，
We may have internalized and distorted performative scripts about sex and love and community, and we may be conditioned to objectify ourselves and others to value superficial attractiveness and also we may view sex or relationships as conquests and not as experiences of the joy of getting to be with other people to be a part of other people and to have them be a part of us, us be a part of them. There's not a natural exchange in sexuality or community and it can be hard to rest in the simple realness of being present with another person. But beyond just specific sexual trauma, many of us carry attachment wounds
我们可能已经内化并扭曲了关于性、爱和社区的表演性脚本，我们可能被训练得将自己和他人客体化，去重视肤浅的吸引力。我们也可能将性或关系视为征服，而不是一种与他人共处、成为他人一部分、让对方成为我们一部分的快乐体验。在性和社区中没有自然的交流，很难安于与另一个人共处的简单真实感。但除了特定的性创伤之外，我们许多人还带有依恋创伤，
that further complicate our experience of the lover archetype. If we grew up with inconsistent caregivers, absence or betrayal of trust, we may have an ambivalent relationship with closeness and vulnerability, desperately wanting to be seen and held but terrified of being engulfed or controlled again or abandoned again. We may lurch between anxious clinging and avoidant pushing away. Without a template for secure bonding, it can feel like an impossible dilemma. A choice between a soul crushing loneliness and a soul crushing enmeshment. Take a moment to sense into your own unique configuration of lover wounds and capacity and scan your body and subtle energy field for the places where you feel most alive,
这进一步复杂化了我们对“爱人”原型的体验。如果我们成长过程中照顾者不一致、缺席或背叛了信任，我们可能会对亲密和脆弱产生矛盾的心理，既渴望被看见和拥抱，又恐惧再次被吞噬、控制或抛弃。我们可能在焦虑的依恋和回避的推开之间摇摆。没有安全联结的模板，这感觉就像一个不可能的困境。在令人心碎的孤独和令人心碎的纠缠之间做出选择。花点时间去感受你自己独特的“爱人”创伤和能力，扫描你的身体和微妙的能量场，寻找那些你感到最有活力、
energy field for the places where you feel most alive, awake and adventurous in love and communion and in experience. And what helps you relax into the soft animal of your being and rest in the radical communion with yourself, with others, with life, what stops you from letting go, what kicks you out of that connected consensual flow and into patterns of grasping, chasing, fighting, or fighting. And you might place a hand on your heart or your belly or your middle of your stomach or two hands while you're sitting on your thighs and imagine breathing a sense of safe, warm and accepting presence into that part of you and feel the layers of shame and fear and frozen tension begin to melt into the light of loving gaze and awareness and send a message of reassurance
最清醒、在爱与共融及体验中最具冒险精神的地方。是什么帮助你放松进入你那柔软的动物本性，并在与自己、他人和生命的彻底共融中安息？是什么阻止了你放手，是什么将你从那种连接的、共识的流动中踢出，陷入抓取、追逐、争斗或战斗的模式？你可以把一只手放在心口、腹部或胃部中间，或者在坐着时将双手放在大腿上，想象将一种安全、温暖和接纳的临在感呼吸进你身体的那个部位，感受那些羞耻、恐惧和冰冷的紧张感开始在爱的凝视和觉知之光中融化，并发送一条安慰的信息
to your younger selves. It's okay. You're allowed to want, you're allowed to feel, you're allowed to receive, you are safe to open and surrender to now. And let yourself dissolve a little more into this luminous field. And feel how vast you can become when you let go. And you open yourself to relationship and connection and feel the tendrils of your essence intertwining with essence of everything around you. Natural and man-made, subtle and concrete, and sense that there is no real separation
给你的内在小孩。没关系。你被允许渴望，你被允许感受，你被允许接受，你现在可以安全地敞开和臣服。让自己在这个发光的场域中再多消融一点。感受当你放手时，你可以变得多么广阔。当你向关系和连接敞开自己，感受你本质的卷须与周围一切事物的本质交织在一起。无论是自然的还是人造的，微妙的还是具体的，感知到你与世界之间并没有真正的分离，
between you and the world, it's all made of the same glowing stuff, the same dust, all longing to be touched, pretending it is separate, but wanting to be connected again to itself. And finally, let's look at the child archetype, the last archetype we're working with today. And the child is our original innocence, our wonder and spontaneity prior to the masks and adaptations that we had to take on to survive. And it is our capacity for presence, playfulness, and unabashed, unafraid self-expression. And when we're at home in the divine energy of the child, we feel safe and held and free to be exactly who and what we are. We don't think about who we are. We just are it. And reconnecting with the child is not so much an imagining as a remembering. And our bodies are supple and relaxed.
它都是由同样的闪光物质、同样的尘埃构成的，都在渴望被触碰，假装自己是独立的，却又渴望重新连接到自身。最后，让我们看看“孩子”原型，这是我们今天研究的最后一个原型。孩子是我们最初的纯真、惊奇和自发性，在我们需要为了生存而戴上面具和进行适应之前。它是我们保持临在、玩耍和无拘无束、无所畏惧地自我表达的能力。当我们安住在孩子那神圣的能量中时，我们感到安全、被接纳，并自由地成为我们本来就是的样子。我们不去想我们是谁，我们只是存在。与孩子重新连接与其说是想象，不如说是回忆。我们的身体柔软而放松，
And our faces are bright. And we are involuntarily animated and naturally open. And our voices resonate. And we laugh. And we cry and we meet life with a beginner's mind, led more by curiosity than fear and led more by intuition than intellect. But as you've guessed by now, many of us did not get the experiences we needed to establish a secure and a joyful inner child. We were born into a world of overwhelming circumstances and did not get everything that we needed to attune
我们的面孔明亮，我们不由自主地充满活力，自然地敞开。我们的声音产生共鸣，我们欢笑，我们哭泣，我们以初学者的心态面对生活，更多地被好奇心而非恐惧所引导，更多地被直觉而非理智所引导。但正如你现在所猜到的，我们许多人并没有得到建立一个安全、快乐的内在小孩所需的体验。我们出生在一个充满压倒性环境的世界里，并没有得到我们需要的一切来协调，
based on the natural limitations on the child energy and the parts of ourselves that we had to peel away. Robert Bly would say that we put into the long bag that we drag behind ourselves, that we call the shadow until we hear elements of the bag call to us over the course of the lifespan. And then we have to reach for them and take them out of the bag and reclaim them and reconnect to them. And we had to contort ourselves in all kinds of ways to maintain a precarious sense of okayness. And we may have coped by becoming precociously self-sufficient, perfectionistic or parentified, convincing ourselves that we were more mature
基于孩子能量的自然局限性以及我们不得不剥离的那些自我部分。罗伯特·布莱会说，我们把这些放入我们拖在身后的大袋子里，我们称之为“阴影”，直到我们在生命历程中听到袋子里的元素在呼唤我们。然后我们必须伸手去拿它们，把它们从袋子里拿出来，重新认领并与它们重新连接。我们不得不以各种方式扭曲自己，以维持一种不稳定的“还可以”的感觉。我们可能通过变得早熟、自给自足、完美主义或承担父母角色来应对，说服自己我们比在内心深处感受到的更成熟、
and more in control than we ever really felt in our gut. Or we may have submitted completely, making ourselves as small and as silent and unseen as possible. And if we were subjected to chronic chaos or neglect or violence, we may have spent much of our childhood in a state of hyper-vigilant alarm, on constant lookout for threats and escape routes, marinating in stress hormones. We armored our bodies and braced ourselves against life, viewing it as an adversary that we had to begrudgingly deal with, not an experience to awaken.
更有掌控力。或者我们可能完全顺从，让自己尽可能渺小、沉默和不被看见。如果我们遭受了长期的混乱、忽视或暴力，我们可能在童年的大部分时间里处于高度警觉的惊恐状态，不断寻找威胁和逃生路线，沉浸在压力荷尔蒙中。我们武装了自己的身体，抵御生活，将其视为我们不得不勉强应对的对手，而不是一种觉醒的体验。
And we lost touch with our inborn capacity for ease, delight, and spontaneous authenticity. And we may have coped by disappearing into fantasy, compulsively caretaking others, or acting out in ways that screamed for help that we could not directly request. Our woundedness led us to manifest through our behavior that we needed help and maybe people heard it and we rejected them or reacted angrily or maybe no one heard. But even if our early environment was relatively safe and stable we may still have internalized messages that it wasn't okay to fully inhabit our child nature. Steeped in a culture that rushes children to be little adults, that commodifies and sexualizes their innocence, that shames their sensitivity and unrestrained vitality, many of us learned to put a bushel over our light and we got the message that intensity was too much,
我们失去了与生俱来的轻松、愉悦和自发真实性的能力。我们可能通过沉溺于幻想、强迫性地照顾他人，或者以尖叫着寻求帮助但无法直接表达的方式行事来应对。我们的创伤导致我们通过行为表现出我们需要帮助，也许有人听到了，但我们拒绝了他们或愤怒地回应，也许根本没人听到。但即使我们早年的环境相对安全稳定，我们可能仍然内化了“完全活出孩子本性是不对的”这样的信息。沉浸在一种催促孩子成为小大人的文化中，这种文化将他们的纯真商品化和性化，羞辱他们的敏感和不受约束的活力，我们许多人学会了掩盖自己的光芒，我们得到的信息是：强度太大了，
that questions were disrespectful or bad, that big feelings were dramatic, that emotion was impractical, that needing help and comfort was weakness. And so we peeled these parts of ourselves off comfort was weakness. And so we peeled these parts of ourselves off and put them in the long bag we dragged behind ourselves that Robert Bly calls the shadow. And in Jungian psychology and parts-based therapy, we have to hear those parts and take them back out of the bag. And scrambling to be accepted and approved of, we built our identities on the shaky ground of other people's projections and expectations. Take a moment to reflect on your own journey with the child archetype. Do you have memories of feeling truly safe to play, explore, and express yourself? What did you most love to do as a little one
提问是不敬或坏的，强烈的情感是戏剧化的，情绪是不切实际的，需要帮助和安慰是软弱的。于是我们剥离了这些部分，把它们放进我们拖在身后的长袋子里，罗伯特·布莱称之为“阴影”。在荣格心理学和基于部分的疗法中，我们必须倾听这些部分，并把它们从袋子里拿出来。为了被接受和认可，我们把身份建立在他人投射和期望的摇摇欲坠的基础上。花点时间反思一下你自己的“孩子”原型之旅。你有过感到真正安全地去玩耍、探索和表达自己的记忆吗？作为小孩子时，你最喜欢做什么？
before the world told you who you should be? Are you living the life you chose or are you living the life that chose you as the Jason Isbell song goes? How did experiences of powerlessness, betrayal, and scarcity impact your ability to trust life and other people? What younger parts of you might still be stuck in painful past experiences or frozen in fear or grief? You might invite one of those little selves to come sit on your lap or to curl up in your arms. Infuse your experience with the warmth of a loving parent, an older sibling, a protective ancestor. ancestor and feel the armored places begin to soften, the held breaths begin to release and offer your younger self the words they needed to hear. I see you, I hear you, I am here for you, I will keep you safe.
在世界告诉你你应该成为谁之前？你是在过你选择的生活，还是像杰森·伊斯贝尔的歌里唱的那样，在过那种选择了你的生活？无力感、背叛和匮乏的经历如何影响了你信任生活和他人的能力？你内心深处哪些年轻的部分可能仍然困在痛苦的过去经历中，或者冻结在恐惧或悲伤中？你可以邀请其中一个小的自我来坐在你的膝盖上，或者蜷缩在你的怀里。用慈爱的父母、年长的兄弟姐妹或保护性的祖先的温暖来注入你的体验，感受那些武装起来的地方开始软化，屏住的呼吸开始释放，并对你年轻的自我说出他们需要听到的话：我看见你，我听见你，我在这里陪你，我会保护你的安全。
You can hurt and you can heal. You can cry and you can laugh. You don't have to be anything other than what you are. You are enough. You are me. And I am enough. I feel what I am supposed to feel. And I am what I am supposed to feel and I am what I am supposed to be. And let your inner child know that it's never too late to get your needs met, to renegotiate your early contracts, to come out of hiding and exile. If it feels right, you might spend a few moments in spontaneous, childlike play. You may flitter your digits in your limbs about, put on some music and dance wildly without paying attention to how you look.
你可以受伤，也可以治愈。你可以哭泣，也可以欢笑。你不需要成为除了你本身之外的任何东西。你已经足够好了。你就是我。我也足够好了。我感受我应该感受的，我就是我应该成为的。让你的内在小孩知道，满足你的需求、重新协商你早年的契约、走出隐藏和流放，永远都不晚。如果感觉合适，你可以花点时间进行自发的、孩子气的玩耍。你可以动动手指和四肢，放点音乐，不顾形象地疯狂跳舞。
Go outside and look up at the sky and wonder. Sing at the top of your lungs or try funny accents and make yourself laugh. Get out some crayons or a pencil and just doodle without thinking. Draw what you imagine. If you access safe nurture, then you can let yourself go and stomp and puddles or roll down a grassy hill and let yourself make a mess. Forget about work, break rules, be unapologetic in your body and your joy. And from this place of primal aliveness and undefinedness, feel how the whole world begins to shimmer with sentience and invitation. Trees
去户外抬头看天空，感受惊奇。大声歌唱，或者尝试滑稽的口音，让自己大笑。拿出蜡笔或铅笔，不假思索地涂鸦。画出你想象的东西。如果你获得了安全的滋养，那么你可以让自己去踩水坑，或者在草地上打滚，让自己弄得一团糟。忘记工作，打破规则，在你的身体和快乐中毫无歉意。从这个原始的活力和未定义的处境中，感受整个世界如何开始闪烁着感知和邀请。树木
beckon you to climb them. Bugs call out to be befriended. Nature itself longs to be watched. Smell flowers. Stroke the grass with your fingertips. The earth can hold you in a wider and a wilder embrace than the human trance of separation and scarcity and rules and judgment and forethought and reactive attachments and painful memories. So just participate in that embrace and hold yourself and let the world hold you and know that you are where you are supposed to be. And there is no self and no other and there is no subject or object, only an endless dance of reciprocal recognition and belonging and being. And this is your original face. It is your essential nature. And as we prepare to close this practice, take a few moments to feel the spectrum of all of these archetypal energies moving through your cognition and your behavior and your body and feel them as older and deeper things that come through you
召唤你去攀爬。虫子呼唤着与你结为朋友。大自然本身渴望被注视。闻闻花朵。用指尖抚摸草地。大地能以比人类那种分离、匮乏、规则、评判、预谋、反应性依恋和痛苦记忆的迷梦更宽广、更狂野的怀抱来拥抱你。所以，参与到那个拥抱中去，拥抱你自己，让世界拥抱你，并知道你就在你应该在的地方。没有自我，没有他者，没有主体或客体，只有相互认同、归属和存在的无尽舞蹈。这就是你原本的面目。这是你的本质。当我们准备结束这次练习时，花点时间感受所有这些原型能量在你认知、行为和身体中流动的光谱，感受它们是比你更古老、更深邃的东西，它们通过你而来，
but are not all of you at any time As the late James Hellman was wont to quote W.H. Auden, We are lived by forces that we pretend to understand. The warrior, the magician, the queen, the king, the lover, and the child are all alive within you in their own unique configuration, and they each have gifts to bring and wounds to heal and fears to face and powers to claim. And the more you turn towards them with compassion and curiosity, the more integrated and accessible they become. But none of them is all of you.
但在任何时候它们并不代表全部的你。正如已故的詹姆斯·希尔曼喜欢引用W.H.奥登的话：“我们被我们自以为理解的力量所驱动。”战士、魔术师、女王、国王、爱人和孩子都在你内心以其独特的配置活着，它们每个人都有礼物要带来，有创伤要治愈，有恐惧要面对，有力量要认领。你越是带着同情心和好奇心转向它们，它们就越整合、越容易触及。但它们中的任何一个都不是全部的你。
But you are all of them. And remember this isn't about perfecting a static set of qualities or balancing things on a scale, but about learning to dance fluidly and skillfully, consciously and unconsciously, with different parts of your psyche and your soma. You are becoming porous and less rigid so that these things can move freely and that you can trust them without thinking about them. And through that you can learn to trust yourself again. And there will be times when you need the warrior's laser-focused mindset or the child's unfiltered delight. The magician's clever shape-shifting or the queen's
但你拥有它们全部。记住，这并不是要完善一套静态的品质或在天平上平衡事物，而是要学习如何与你心灵和身体的不同部分流畅、熟练、有意识和无意识地共舞。你正在变得多孔且不再僵化，这样这些能量就能自由流动，你就能在不假思索的情况下信任它们。通过这一点，你可以学会再次信任自己。会有一些时候，你需要战士那种激光般专注的心态，或者孩子那种未经滤的喜悦。魔术师那种巧妙的变形，或者女王那种
deep holding presence. You contain multitudes and the world needs the full brilliance of your unadorned, unarmored and unadulterated light. And trust that your nervous system is wired for healing and your body is coded for wholeness and every experience you've ever had and especially the most painful ones. You've been compost for the flowering of your unique and individuated self. And as you feel ready, begin to deepen your breath and bring your awareness back to the space around you. And wiggle your fingers and wiggle your toes and stretch your arms overhead. Let out a big sigh,
深沉的持守临在。你包含万千，世界需要你那未经修饰、未被武装、纯粹光芒的全部辉煌。相信你的神经系统是为治愈而连接的，你的身体被编码为完整，你经历过的每一次体验，尤其是那些最痛苦的，都是你独特且个体化自我绽放的肥料。当你准备好时，开始加深呼吸，将你的觉知带回你周围的空间。动动你的手指，动动你的脚趾，把手臂伸过头顶。长长地叹一口气，
and let your spine be loose, but strong and upright. And open your eyes and take a moment to look around, feeling your senses resyncing with the outer environment. And if you like, you might place a hand on your heart environment and if you like you might place a hand on your heart and feel gratitude and blessing for your courageous, tender, and resilient nature. And if you forget sometimes, if you fall back asleep, that's okay. That is part of this process too. There is no other journey but yours and there is no other moment than the one you are in. There is nowhere to get to but here and you can come back to it anytime. There is nothing to do but to be. You are
让你的脊椎放松，但保持强壮和挺直。睁开眼睛，花点时间环顾四周，感受你的感官与外部环境重新同步。如果你愿意，你可以把一只手放在心口，为自己勇敢、温柔和坚韧的本性感到感激和祝福。如果你有时忘记了，如果你又睡着了，那也没关系。这也是这个过程的一部分。除了你自己的旅程，没有别的旅程；除了你所在的这一刻，没有别的时刻。除了这里，没有别的地方可去，你可以随时回到这里。除了“存在”，什么都不用做。你
already what you seek. Already whole beyond belief. It's just a matter of practice and patience and a deep, deep remembering of what you already know. There is nothing to learn, only to remember. So please be kind, wildly kind to yourself and take care of your innocence and never give up on the possibility of your joyful genius. The world is waiting for you and you are longing for the world. Remember that you are free. So Hey guys, I wanted to pop in here to give you a quick reminder that we do this podcast for free and there are significant expenses associated with it, including the biggest resource of my life right now, which is time. One of the
已经是你所寻求的。已经完整得超乎想象。这只是练习、耐心和对你已知事物进行深刻、深刻回忆的问题。没有什么可学的，只有回忆。所以请善待自己，极其善待自己，照顾好你的纯真，永远不要放弃你那快乐天才的可能性。世界在等你，你也渴望着世界。记住你是自由的。嘿，伙计们，我想插播一下，提醒大家我们免费制作这个播客，并且伴随着巨大的开支，包括我现在生活中最大的资源——时间。其中
things that would really help us and hopefully would help you would be to check out one of our sponsors, Hardy Nutritionals. Hardy is a vitamin company that I never encountered the advertising of. We heard over and over again from multiple people with treatment-resistant anxiety and dopamine disorders like bipolar disorder and other things that they had tried everything and Hardy was what worked. And so I checked them out and they have really good research. I'm not a fan of a lot of the BS
一件真正能帮助我们，也希望对你有帮助的事情，就是去看看我们的赞助商Hardy Nutritionals。Hardy是一家维生素公司，我以前从未接触过他们的广告。我们反复从多位患有难治性焦虑症和多巴胺障碍（如双相情感障碍等）的人那里听说，他们尝试过一切方法，而Hardy是唯一有效的产品。所以我去了解了一下，他们确实有很好的研究。我不喜欢很多
that's in the supplement and wellness space. Hardy paid for a lot of research on their product. And when I ordered some for myself, I saw a big difference in my life. And my wife made fun of me, thought it was gonna be Alex Jones selling vitamins on the radio And when she tried them, she really liked them, too There's a lot of data about how they can reduce the symptoms of ADHD
补充剂和健康领域里的废话。Hardy为他们的产品投入了大量研究资金。当我为自己订购了一些时，我发现我的生活有了很大的不同。我妻子还取笑我，以为这会像亚历克斯·琼斯在电台上卖维生素一样。但当她尝试后，她也非常喜欢。有很多数据表明它们可以减轻多动症的症状，
Without medications or lower your need for medication also manage some of the effects of autism spectrum disorder and a whole lot of other things newer research Around nutrition is saying that the synergistic effects of multiple things being planned to work together is a lot more effective than one thing working alone. You can get a lot of information about that on our website. Or you can head over to GetHardy, that's G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y and use offer code TAPROOT for 15% off.
无需药物，或者降低你对药物的需求，也能管理一些自闭症谱系障碍的影响以及许多其他问题。关于营养的最新研究表明，多种事物协同作用的效果远比单一事物单独作用要有效得多。你可以在我们的网站上获得很多相关信息。或者你可以前往GetHardy，即G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y，并使用优惠码TAPROOT享受15%的折扣。
It would help them, it would help me, and it also would probably help you. One of the more frequent things that patients and people in the randomized controlled trials that Hardy conducted report is that they feel more themself, more focused and more effective at getting things done, which can result in all of us having a little bit more time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这会帮助他们，会帮助我，也可能会帮助你。Hardy进行的随机对照试验中，患者和参与者报告最频繁的事情之一是，他们感觉更像自己，更专注，更有效地完成事情，这可以让我们所有人多出一点时间。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。